alors il me reste peu de temps à vivre
je voudrais prendre rendez vous avec un
conseiller
[Musique]
je suis sûr que vous connaissez le
processus
lorsque vous savez que vous êtes
mourante vous pouvez vous faire cloner
ta peau et radieuse j'aime ton t-shirt
[Musique]
mais la vie vous a lancé une balle
courbe vous n'êtes plus mourante
le duel à mort aura lieu dans un an
environ attendez une seconde vous avez
dit tu es la mort
pas vous laisser circuler toutes les
deux à jamais c'est très ridicule
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux
oui
je ne te crois pas
[Musique]
il me semble que je fais une taille de
moins de toi je vais la tuer c'est tout
il ya un an traîné le corps humain et
j'ai fait semblant d'être moi alors que
je suis en vie
je sorte avec elle ou pas j'ai plus
envie d'être avec toi
[Musique]
il faut toujours utiliser le pistolet si
c'est une option qui trouve les armes à
fait sûr fait et ennuyeuse
si c'est la différence entre la vie et
la mort il ya pas de honte à être
enduits
des petits jeux psychologiques ne vont
pas marché
tu étais censé me remplacer pas volé ma
vie
[Musique]
non
je dois partir je ferai tout pour
qu'elle ne la vole pas
quelles sont mes chances elles sont
nulles la certitude absolue n'existe pas
mais dans votre cas c'est plus que
certains
[Musique]
ton amitié vraiment très importante elle
me manquera à son décès et à ce propos
tu as des nouvelles
[Musique]